what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic Wonder today we have some
news about some new trailers and new
footage for some upcoming Marvel and
also Marvel Sony projects as it turns
out we are about to get a lot of new
trailers and new footage we are also
about to get the DC's Blue Beetle
trailer as well so within the next two
days April 2nd and April 3rd we are
going to get trailers and footage for
four different superhero projects three
being Marvel one being DC now let's
first start off with Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 if you are trying to get
tickets and be the first to see it when
it comes out in theaters you can do that
Monday April 3rd that's right it looks
like tickets are going to open up April
3rd as it is posted on an online
ticketing page for Flix Brewhouse on
their page it says bad news for
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 tickets
for this movie aren't yet available to
buy tickets will go on sale from Monday
April 3rd 2023 9 9am EDT so you can get
your tickets then but this also means
that we probably are getting some type
of new footage for Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. this is a tradition with
Marvel it's usually not a full trailer
it's sort of a hey tickets are on sale
now trailer with some new footage put in
there however again this is what Marvel
typically does and they've done this
with all of the past films in the past
few years so we have no reason to not
believe that we're getting new footage
for Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 on
Monday April 3rd but sooner than that
tomorrow comes the secret Invasion
trailer the second one as we've already
gotten one trailer already and yesterday
Vanity Fair released a lot of plot
details about the upcoming series and
you can check out my video on that if
you want to learn more but the new
trailer has been announced by Disney
plus and Marvel Studios in a recent TV
spot that the full second trailer for
secret invasion is coming Sunday April
2nd during the MLB game between
Philadelphia Phillies and the Texas
Rangers is going to be on ESPN and of
course they're going to put this out on
YouTube as well immediately after the
game starts at 7 pm eastern time we
don't have an exact time of when the
actual trailer will drop but sometime
during the game so 7 P.M eastern time
and on so tomorrow look out for that new
secret Invasion trailer and then on
Monday again we have two other trailers
now the Guardians trailer again is not a
full official trailer just new footage
but Sony According to some insiders like
Grace Randolph and Daniel rpk is going
to release the new trailer for
Spider-Man across the spider-verse and
what we've heard rumors have it that
Toby Maguire Spider-Man and Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man along with Tom
Hollands of course is going to be
joining the animated spider-verse so
hopefully we get a tease for them in
this new trailer we don't really have an
exact time of when this could come it
could come very early in the morning
midday or afternoon if we hear anything
we'll do a video on it but be ready at
the beginning of the day and also Warner
Brothers is releasing the Blue Beetle
trailer this is a project that a lot of
DC fans and superhero fans in general
are really excited about and of course
very interested to see how it's going to
go and how it's going to fit in either
the old DCU or the new DCU many people
that have seen the trailer or have seen
footage of this or simply the cast that
has been involved with this film have
all said that it's really great so can't
wait to see that on Monday along with a
new trailer for across the spider verse
new footage for Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 and then tomorrow night a secret
Invasion trailer let us know how excited
you are for all of these new trailers
coming and footage in the next couple of
days leave your comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest news you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof
thank you